actor comedian former Saturday Night
Live cast member David Spade back on the
program
David good morning how are you Daniel
son first time long time
hey uh Dez Bryant they tried a head case
for a head case I like it who do you
have head cases like women you don't
hang around head cases do you do you
have head cases around that's all like
that's all like I hang out with this
poison in the locker room in my life
it's sandwiched on a head case
no Sam was the easiest woman I mean I've
done movies and I've done things where I
get what they mean about that you know
you get a guy in a locker room that's
troubling it infects the whole team so I
kind of movie if somebody's a jerk or
dozen other lines or comes late or
starts problems it just makes the whole
movie dread going to work every day it's
tough you don't have to give names but
can you give us a story of somebody who
was a headcase unprofessional that you
don't know I actually there's been a few
but I remember one time I did a movie in
there's a there's a guy shooting a gun
next to me and he was gonna do he just
pretends and then they add it in later
because you know it's too loud to put a
blank right next to my head so uh he
does it with a real blank he tells props
I really need one this is like illegal
now but he doesn't it scares the you
know out of me and I freaked out and
then I screamed at him and here that I
wanted a real reaction but then he got
one for the next two hours basically
because I stormed off whoa had a real
problem we're talking a guy that was
saying like when you go to the set these
are little things but you know cuz
you're in the biz that he goes make sure
when they go you know you're on the set
in five they're not ready then they go
ready ready which means no BS let's go
so you can get in the van you go to the
set you stand the Sun and he was the guy
that said hey
make sure you never told us this but we
realize we said make sure everyone's out
there standing and when they are then
I'll leave my trailer oh boy
usually all at the same time you know
it's like knock-knock everyone's going
alright you see cars pulling on you see
one and know you're walking to the set
and you get there and you know his whole
thing was it's a Power Move you got to
be there and then and then I trickle in
when I do you like it
okay let's guess here Paulie do you have
a guess on whose space star googling
everything but I'll email you after okay
that's fine so I the way I did here
might go ahead
no no go ahead no it's your time when
you said what am i selling you did I do
agree you to give a speech that you
study everyone before they come on and
that's fine you know me well enough
where you don't have to know every up to
minute thing I'm doing I get it III go
chunks without doing anything and then
this audiobook and the and the Netflix
and we came out the same day which is
very rare so it's a bit complicated and
I do look a little like Joe Dirt I was
hearing that and I knew that but I I
actually sort of am more like Snake
Plissken because when you see the whole
look and what I'm doing and fighting and
everything it's a little different wait
so Escape from New York is the reference
here yeah I sort of look like that but I
have a New Hampshire accent that was the
hardest part are you doing your New
Hampshire accent right now yes oh that's
very good
I'm sure I'm sure Sandler helped you
with that oh well yeah everything he was
telling me to do it and picture me doing
it at a table read I can't even act when
I do a normal life and then he wants me
to do I go are you sure you weren't
supposed to get like you know Robert De
Niro fur so I am trying to I have to go
to dialect codes which even they were
rolling your eyes like come on guy like
you've been to skate
this career for fifteen years like I'm
doing the exact same move mumbling lines
in the background are we really gonna
try this you want to call it quits and I
think they were just motivating me like
Good Will Hunting or something so I go
out there and I do it I go you know it's
like macking back you know and I go that
stuff and they go no that's Boston I go
15 miles away okay
and then I do another one they go that's
more Maine I go come on are you joking
like who cares my audience is nine year
olds they don't know what's going on who
helped you with your junior dialect
they're gonna watch the little moving
think if this came from New York sequel
ah Joe Dirt I handle that oh you did
okay yeah the lazy southern thing is and
believe me people are like so you were
more from Kentucky or Arkansas on that I
go it's called whatever these stocks
easy is southern I have no idea what
you're talking about
they're like warm Tallahassee or
Jacksonville I go I don't know you're
talking on
I don't even travel to the east very
much so I just skim through on that one
but I love Joe Dirt do I get more I mean
obviously I've done what 25 movies a lot
3 work it's not gonna get me in the hall
of fame who are the all-star game but
it's a it's a decent hitting percentage
and it's always Joe Dirt Tommy Boy when
I go out so and then grown ups and then
arms to and then you you could always
tell what they like the most you know
what I mean like what people talk about
they don't always tell you which ones
they hate you know what I mean but did
you know the farmers a lot yeah we were
in Benchwarmers together
yeah mentors was where we started our
bromance yeah that's way back yeah but
but when it comes to Tommy did you know
Tommy Boy was gonna be good I mean I
listen I was so naive and I I've been on
movie set since but that was one of my
first ones ever after
probably Coneheads where I had a decent
part and we were just trying to crack
each other up with like the scene was
old flat so you go hey I go finally then
buddy and wardrobe of a clip-on tie I go
let's just add like a dumb joke here or
housekeeping or you know just let's add
jokes we say in real life even though
even sometimes it made no sense
like even a director goes why are you
doing housekeeping why are you adding
spanked revision in here I go it just
just puff it up cause there's really
nothing it's a movie about selling
brakes folks like Lorne made them they
made them do the move it us because we
want to know pitching to go get this
we're in Iowa where we oh hi oh and
we're selling brake pads and they're
like that's all we need to hear so but
you've got to feel proud though of all
the movies that have ever been done on
selling brake shoes that is the best
yeah right I consider it the best I
don't know if everybody else too how old
were you when you did tell me what yes
middle of saying live I was probably 27
28 it was called Billy the third and it
was called Billy the third a Midwestern
that was on the cover page that's how we
read it that's how we were gonna shoot
it and guess in the next room who was
doing Billy Madison so we had to switch
it and then we couldn't think of a name
the whole shoot and how did you come up
with Tommy Boy his name was Tommy the
dad calls him Tommy Boy once or twice
and then it was called rocky road it was
called big time and then at the last
second someone hit me up in those called
Tommy Boy now I go okay I didn't love it
but now you can't even think of a
different name you know what I mean yeah
it just sounds weird at the time but
worked out the The Fatman line when he's
got on your jacket is that is that
scripted um it wasn't in there but it
was because we shared a tiny office at
work and he would stand behind me and do
nothing and he would get you know
sketches handed to him on a gold platter
I lost Graham language he has 90 moves
and I have one right just in sarcastic
so I have to write all these weekend
update' stuff and he bore B
I'm just waiting to kill and read
through and you go uh even turn around
and I go dude I have stuff to do and he
goes turn around and I go if this is
fact I'm a little coat it's not funny
anymore it's over it's played and he
goes no I knew stuff and then I turn
around he's got my little Levi jacket on
it and then we we just it's like Tina on
the movie you go hey what if he puts on
my coat and does the stupid thing we
don't work that's so dumb and then he
sang the song just on the set just to be
funny thanks by the way
smart director smart editor keep it in
we were doing the crap like that all the
time and you're just like hey if you
guys think that's funny keep it in if
you don't we have to lose it but at
least let us try it and then you know
they go into a test screening with a
couple extra ones like that and then
they go and they kind of work we'll just
keep you never know what people gonna
repeat you never know there's lines
there's lines and children I got the
coulomb me
where's in the shower and then people
will just you know Twitter me I had to
put on be 30 times and you know know
what what things work so you do all
these movies and you try and then you
things click you know and growing up so
it was maze and then you know and
Benchwarmers it was amazing and hassle
lead and you just lost your spot at
video spot or wherever you know he said
there's a lot of throw aways David's got
a Polaroid guy in a snapshot world
that's available now exclusively on cat
what did I say snapshot again
Oh David Spade and it's a Polaroid guy
in a snap
chant world available now exclusive the
years streaming now on netflix so both
out at the same time which is not your
typical marketing but David somehow
pulled it off here so the father of the
year movie is a Netflix yeah and then so
the audiobook is number two they just
Oh first week well congrats you know
night and I hate that sir I hate to
mention that I hate it no no I don't but
then there's also and that that audio
book is about like how things were now
versus when I grew up like with
Polaroid's you know how I have to live
with the snapchat stuff and everything's
different and just basically flipping
around like what it's like now there's
just growing up and father of the year
what is that about
[Laughter]
that's right all right um no it's it's
father of the year me and these me any
other dad
Nate facts and we are kids challenges to
a fight and then we I'm a drunk New
Hampshire dad so I fight everybody in
the town all the time so I did I try to
fight him the whole movie and we getting
about and fights it's pretty funny
though I have to say they already told
me not whatever anyway I think it's
funny you are you're horrible you're
horrible you are I know but I heard one
of your guys said he saw the trailer and
it was a funny that's a good start and
which one of you guys saw McLovin use
dad this weekend me and my wife we're
gonna get some popcorn at home over to
watch father Pauly Spade have you heard
Pauly do is a impression of you yeah I
will say yeah I probably laugh like that
and okay I really take the high road
here yeah I like Andrew Luck better and
I do like Shannon Sharpe yeah
but police is good yep only dizzle and
because it doesn't even I recognize
nothing for me when I hear you guys are
all oh so that must mean I am unaware of
yeah yeah Paulie do it again just think
of these poor girls that have to go to
dinner with me and then I'm like doing
that up for everything I say and they're
like good lord get me out of here how do
you pull off conversation though for
four hours and they're half your age
like is everything a joke when you go to
dinner with these Quran blogaid yeah I
just know I hear about their day
hostessing at Houston's or whatever is
doing yeah we go back and forth
she's like I got triple Sat today I'm
like oh my god and she goes that's when
they bring in three tables I was like oh
I sort of figured it out I got it keep
going if you get married yeah can we
come to the reception I get married the
poor they're all that marries me I mean
I can't put her through it I think even
Sandler said don't bother it's just too
it's too stressful for the girl yeah I
wouldn't be fair to her like well you
know it's not fair because you know
Clooney these guys the copier they're
like he's 50 years old Clooney and he's
having the time his life why should he
settle down he's America's bachelor and
then with me they're like it's tragic it
is get your life together
have you ever hung out with DiCaprio
yeah a little bit
how's that it how's that pat down and
then I bought my house no you want
people to see you now I put my hand
inside my head like you know Jimmy
Neutron
I don't know I'm saying hanging out with
DiCaprio it's not believe me every day
but I do see him in events and he's
always nice
I mean surprisingly I've seen him over
the years always cool I saw him with
that old cello thing where he had a one
of those booths or whatever you have you
know like a room where you can watch and
sew a box so I went in there with him
and
we just talked for a half-hour he was
great so cool
you know these guys all kidding aside if
they like comedy
they've must have seen me in something
along the years and they liked a BS
about that and it's great you know you
always sort of have a foot in from old
movies and stuff and then you know then
I bomb out after that but they get
David's audible they know it dies it's a
Polaroid guy in a snapshot world
I smell a wrap-up I know
a snapchat yeah we're gonna wrap it on
no no combines over hey do you want do
you want Josh Rosen to start oh here's
my here's my question okay
I bet in Vegas that they would win over
six games what do you guys think yeah is
that a tough one you know you got the
Rams who are good the Niners improved
Seattle's feels like they're on the way
down a little bit so you got to deal
with that um six wins is a good question
it's like I think you could get seven
wins but I would start Rosen
you think they'll start them I think
there's a great chance
I mean Sam Bradford use these guys I
mean they use these guys he doesn't do
good for two games he's like tainted
donning didn't make it you know so I
think that's unfair you gotta give him a
shot I don't know the other guy is
pretty good right getting out of the
rough yeah uh he tore his shoulder
signing his contract that's that is not
true that is not true okay work on that
window work on that one sports related
jokes yeah yeah you crushed it I got a
whole new field yeah one hitter even a
courtesy one
[Laughter]
good luck with a Polaroid guy in a
snapchat world it's number two on an
audible bestseller list and of course
father
don't bring that up father by the way
it's go ahead father of the year is
streaming now on netflix it's a great
date movie you know what's great is that
when I do a whole interview and the only
laugh is when he does my life look I
laughed there
no you didn't get out no you guys no it
was it but you know as long as it felt
that way Paulie give me a little more
Spade all right I'm not gonna laugh like
that anymore you guys you got a new
laughs what's your new laugh gonna be
yep I'd go with it yeah that's gonna
catch on all right David okay all right
okay
that's David Spade a Polaroid guy in a
snapchat world and father of the year
streaming now on netflix for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]